You've heard me use the term weaponized ignorance
before, weaponized arrogance, weaponized delusions
of grandeur. And what I mean by that, to weaponize
something is to take something and use it
as a weapon. So someone can be arrogant and
someone would also be able to weaponize that
arrogance if they are in a position of power
or whatever the case may be. I have a video
today of weaponised right wing religious delusions.
This is a combination of ignorance, gullibility,
such that you believe everything Trump says,
combined with just straight up religious delusion
and a suit. Some of you may know there are
people in particularly red states who are
packing churches every weekend despite federal
social distancing guidelines that have already
been extended at least until the end of April.
Despite the known reality that social distancing
does help slow the infectious spread of coronavirus.
So CNN reporter Gary Tuchman went to Ohio
to one of these huge churches that's packing
its services full of people. And on the way
out, there was a huge line of cars. It was
almost like you were leaving, you know, a
sporting event or a concert. Huge line of
cars heading out. And Gary Tuchman opens a
woman, opens the window in her car and is
interviewed by Gary Tuchman on the way out.
The woman represents everything that is wrong
with this country. Religious, not in a reasonable
way, but in an outrageous way that is really
more reminiscent of schizophrenic delusions
for which people would normally be medicated
than anything else. With the added layer of
weaponising her arrogance into thinking that,
of course, she knows more about the virus
than the doctors and the Democrats and the
news media. She can't get the virus, she says,
because she is covered in the blood of Jesus.
This is not an exaggeration.
Take a look at the video driving out of this
Ohio parking lot is a woman who just attended
a church service with dozens of other people,
including children.
I ask you about your decision to go to church,
to be inside. I don't. I wouldn't be anywhere
else. Aren't you concerned it could infect
other people if you get sick inside? Now people
will go down. I'm covered in Jesus blood.
I'm covered in blood. Other people who don't
go to this church who you might encounter,
all these people go to this church, but you're
going to be in places where the grocery store
every day. I mean, people are sick from what
happened, but they're not because I'm covered
in blood. Thank you very much.
That was not a skit on Saturday Night Live.
That was not a comedy movie. That's real life.
Those are the people we're relying on to socially
distance with us to try to stop the spread
of Corona virus. We've got some real problems
in this country. The world sees that and they
laugh and they cry. But that's not that rare
here in the United States.
Now, lots of people will say, David, don't
worry, it's Darwinism. It's some kind of,
you know, that's natural selection. She thinks
she's protected by the blood of Jesus. She's
really not. She wants to do this. She will
die. I wish it were that simple. But that's
not how it works when you're talking about
a highly contagious virus. People like that
are infecting other people, whether or not
they suffer. They are going to lead to other
people getting infected. To other people,
some dying. She is not concerned for anyone
else's safety anyway, as you can probably
tell. So this is not about all church. Shiz.
This is not about all religious people. Every
church I've driven by here in Massachusetts
is closed.
They have signs that say, you know, stay at
home. Trust in God and stay at home. If God
exists, God understands we must stay at home
for the shared safety of our communities.
It is not all churches, but it is a lot of
these whacked out megachurches in the Midwest
and in the South. Also, she says she's going
to the grocery store every day, every day,
even if you aren't worried. Any sensible person
should be going as little as possible to the
grocery store. Go once a week, go less if
you're able y y every day. These folks are
actually. We have a crisis in this country
where when we have a challenge to deal with,
half the country is actively working against
us. They're not working against us in a passive
way. They are actively working against us.
And also not that I need to bring this up
to most of you covered in the blood of Jesus.
That entire imagery is vile to me. I don't
know how that's considered a peaceful image
to Christians in any way. But in any case,
this is the cultish nonsense that is actually
killing people. And unfortunately, you know,
I know so many people say, screw her, let
her die.
It's not about her. If it were if that were
only it, I'd still care about the fact that
this woman might die.
But at least I would say she's not endangering
other people. We can't just write it off and
say, well, that too bad for her. She's going
to suffer these decisions, these packed churches.
All of this stuff that is going on, ignoring
the social distancing guidelines is leading
to people dying. The cultish nonsense is literally
killing people.
We'll have more about this on the David Pakman
show Instagram page. Make sure you're following
us on Instagram at David Pakman show while
you're there. Follow me on Instagram
at Pavitt.